the idea of a consensual non-monogamous
relationship is traditionally a taboo
topic and certainly as with gail yeah
now a new CBS n originals document
documentary is exploring exactly what
that looks like consensual non-monogamy
is considered in a relationship
arrangement in which the partners openly
agree to have more than one sexual or
romantic relationship
research shows one in five single adults
have tried consensual non-monogamy at
some point Brooklyn couple Alex and
Brigitte are in an open marriage they
live together but both date other people
Alex discusses what it is like when his
wife has a date planned at home with
someone else he calls it getting sexiled
sex tiling is when you look at the
calendar Oh tomorrow so-and-so is coming
over and Brigitte is hosting that means
that I need to find something to do
either work late or go see a movie or
hang out a friend or go to the bar we've
been together for eight years now and at
least the way I feel as there's so much
unspoken like certainty between us and
this I give credit to Alex Alex is one
of the most loyal people I've ever met
like more than I could ever even hope to
be alex is so loyal like if we do skip a
date night or if he sees somebody like
three nights a week and we haven't had
dinner together yet like I know this
sounds maybe crazy some people but it
really doesn't bother me because I I
just know at the end of the day that
Alex isn't going anywhere
I have not told my mom I haven't told my
stepfather and I haven't told my
stepmother so really all my friends know
you know non family members know but in
terms of family I'm still taking my time
on that before this air is gonna tell
them all
I guess that I just want them to know
that I love them all very much
and it's just very scary for me to tell
them how I really am because the last
thing I want is for them to reject I
probably know now Adam Yamaguchi is the
executive producer of CBS n originals
and joins us to discuss the new
documentary Adam good morning no you
guys are just bursting right
I couldn't even say good morning break
Oh Adam you have to explain this to me
because I don't understand and I don't
like it what are it's Adam what are some
of the biggest misconceptions well I
think one of the biggest misconceptions
is that people assume that this is just
about one big orgy and and the reality
is the people that we talk to say look
this is far more than just about sex or
just about casual sex these people were
actually committed they've agreed that
they will have multiple partners and in
some cases we in the stock may met a
quad that's four people two couples that
are raising a set of children together
yeah but you know having a relationship
is about depending on that person for
things that you need so I think of Alex
there who's sexiled on certain nights
well what if that's the night that he
really needs to have a conversation with
his significant other about what's going
on in his life and they just give that
up I guess
well they I think they would also tell
you that well that's partially why I
have somebody else to go to he has a
girlfriend she has a boyfriend so he is
exiled well he you know has somebody you
know this is the thing I think whatever
consenting adults want to do should be
between consenting adults I get that but
I think about the family structure and I
think about the children and I just
think those things should matter so how
do they navigate that yeah what message
does it send to your children sure I
mean it's a tricky thing that that many
of these couples and end quads and
triads grapple with in fact the the quad
that's raising the children together
acknowledge that this is strange this is
very strange to tell their kids that
they are involved in a quad the way they
sort of look at it is well now you have
four parental figures who can be
instrumental in shaping you and molding
you into adults alright that's looking
at the positive a lot of husbands and
wives look at each other on the couch
right now like don't even act
don't try this at home yeah thank you
very much and you can stream cbsn
originals it's called non-monogamy it's
on right now at CBS news.com slash open